Our equation for profit is looking really good. Except, right now, I have no
idea what m is equal to. Remember that m is just the money that Grant has spent.
Now, we've talked many times before about how the money that Grant spends is
going to be a combination of fixed costs, like his rent, for example, and costs
that scaled the number of items that he makes or the manufacturing costs. Let's
say that each glasses wiper set costs $10 to make, and that Grant makes exactly
as many wiper sets as he sells. In addition, all these fixed costs together,
equal $20,000 per month. If all of this is the case, then how shall we change
the equation for Grant's profit each month? I'd like you to first calculate m,
the money that Grant spends each month, and then plug this value for n into the
equation that we had for p before. Then, simplify to get your final answer. I
know this is a lot to think about in one problem and there are several steps
here. So, just make sure you go through things slowly, take everything one step
at a time, and write all of your work down on a piece of paper.